on soit frédéric se livraient les noms à
comprendre d'avoir qu'est ce que ça
représente cette revendication la russie
c'est assez conséquent en fait j'ai
toujours montré sa sur le sur la carte
c'est que c'est l'équivalent d'environ
deux fois la france alors ça se situe
quelque part ici
et donc c'est la deuxième fois en fait
que la russie soumet un dossier à l'onu
la première fois ils ont dû écouter ça
manque de preuves scientifiques c'est
assez compliqué il faut documenter le
fait que le territoire qui se trouve
sous la mer arctique en fait appartient
à tel ou tel pays alors dans cette
bataille de l'article il ya plusieurs
pays évidemment il ya la russie mais
aussi la norvège et le danemark avec le
groenland il ya le canada et les états
unis par le biais de l'alaska et on
comprend bien que l'enjeu principal sans
les ressources naturelles a le pétrole
notamment
bah oui céline c'est pas pour les beaux
yeux du petit rhône et roger la maison
du père noël évidemment c'est vraiment
bête en magasin c'est triste maintenant
en fait c'est bel et bien pour le
pétrole y en ait beaucoup il y en aurait
au moins 90 milliards de baril de
pétrole ça ça à peu près trois ans de
consommation mondiale y en a encore plus
pour le gaz naturel la seconde zone
orange jusqu'à six ans de consommation
en temps on se rend compte qu'il ya
beaucoup d'argent c'est un beau trésor
allait chercher là à cette revendication
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que ça vient
changer pour le canada c'est clair que
ça met de la pression sur le canada qui
se traînent un peu les pieds dans ce
dossier en fait on a passé outre le
délai de 10 ans qui avait pour présenter
un dossier de façon officielle là on
pense que le canada irait chercher
jusqu'à peu près l'équivalent de la
superficie des trois provinces des
prairies incluant le pôle nord pour
l'instant le canada dit qu'on a toujours
besoin de preuves scientifiques donc au
moment où on se parle en fait il ya deux
brise glaces qui est si en arctique à la
recherche de ses preuves là pour
documenter le tout on est quand même en
avance des états unis qui n'ont même pas
signé la convention des droits de la mer
en arctique donc ils sont vraiment très
loin sur la ligne de départ entre le
canada et la russie aux alliances sont
pas très bonnes
reste que c'est pas demain la veille
quand même que la russie va venir
planter son drapeau sur l'article
exactement ils l'ont déjà fait mais ce
n'est pas légal époque là
s'ils veulent le faire il faudra
attendre probablement cinq dix ans
peut-être pour que les scientifiques
vraiment analyse les preuves qui ont été
recueillis donc ça veut dire qu on est
loin encore de l'exploration et de
l'exploitation ça veut dire qu'il y aura
beaucoup d'eau qui va couler sous les
ponts de l'eau qui avec le réchauffement
climatique proviendra sûrement
glacier finalement oui mais si triste ça
quand même je suis pour un goy merci
beaucoup aux frais pour moi